es wird dann mit der Creme und es wird
mit der Krim enden wo Leute mir selenski
liebe visualpolitik Community die
Halbinsel Krem ist der Elefant im Raum
aller Diskussionen über den Ukraine
kriegt ja hundertelang umkämpft dann
jahrzehntelang das Ibiza der Ukraine ist
sie seit 9 Jahren wieder ein echter
Zankapfel die Sache ist nun mal die
Ukraine wollen sie unbedingt
zurückbekommen aber es ist überhaupt
nicht klar dass die USA und Europa ihren
bei diesen speziellen Anliegen helfen
werden und das sagen nicht nur wir dies
kommt von Anthony blinken den US
Außenminister
Anthony blinken während die Ukraine vor
einer Rückeroberung der Krim der US
Außenminister befürchte dass Bemühungen
die anektierte Halbinsel zurück zur
erobern eine rote Linie für Vladimir
Putin darstellen würden ja ja die vielen
roten Linien des Wladimir vladimirovic
Putin wer kennt sie nicht sie sind fast
schon eine Running Gag egal ob es um die
Lieferung von Langstrecken Artillerie
Panzern oder kämpft jetzt an die Ukraine
gegenüber 16 werden übrigens bald ein
eigenes Video drehen also Abo nicht
vergessen auf jeden Fall wird Putin
nicht müde den besten gebietsmühlenartig
davor zu fahren und seine berühmten
roten Linien ja nicht zu überschreiten
sonst würde er noch weiter eskalieren
und immer schickte dann kurz darauf
seine Tanzbären mettv und Frau hinterher
um dies mitunter durch Atom Drohungen zu
untermauern das Problem sehr sehr viele
auch professionelle Angsthasen fallen
auf diese Blocks herein die mit Tieren
oder verzögern dann wichtige Waffenhilfe
für die Ukraine und verlängern dadurch
den Krieg und das Leid der Ukraine wie
viele ihrer Soldaten und unschuldigen
Zivilisten werden noch sterben müssen
das Scholz und Co endlich kapieren das
Putin eskaliert oder nicht eskaliert
wann es ihm passt unabhängig davon was
der besten tut oder unterlässt das seine
Eskalation Rhetorik nur der
strategischen Manipulation des Gegners
und seiner Verbündeten dient und
keinerlei Grundlage der russischen
Kriegsplanung ist putin wird sein Ding
durchziehen und zwar umso eher je
stärker die Schwäche und das Zögern
seiner Gegner spürt indem wir auf die
russische eskalationspropaganda
hereingefallen sind haben wir viele
Ukraine in den Tod getrieben um diesen
Krieg zu beenden müssen wir aufhören uns
auf die Ängste zu konzentrieren die uns
von Moskau eingeredet werden und
anfangen uns auf die Bedürfnisse zu
konzentrieren die die Ukraine und
kompetente Kommentatoren definieren
University davon abgesehen sind dem
verbrecherischen russischen Diktator in
der sowieso nicht mehr allzu viele rote
Linien geblieben eine davon ist
allerdings eben die Creme um die es in
diesem Video geht aber warum eigentlich
werdet ihr euch fragen wieso stellt
ausgerichtet die Creme eine ganz
besonders glaubwürdige rote Linie da nun
aus zwei Gründen der erste ist dass die
Rückeroberung auf den ersten Blick eine
ohne mögliche Aufgabe zu sein scheint
der zweite und wichtigere Grund ist dass
einige meinen gemäß der russischen
nuklear Doktrin Bikini mit Putin
tatsächlich das Recht Atomwaffen
einzusetzen wenn ihr Russen nicht mehr
in der Lage während sie konventionell zu
verteidigen denn für die Russen ist
diese Halbinsel nicht einmal ein Teil
der Ukraine gemäß ihrer Auslegung
handelt es sich um eine eigenständiges
Gebiet der Russischen Föderation es gibt
in Russland sogar ein beliebtes pop-lied
namens delanjavis Sisters also made in
the USA es ist so etwas wie die
aliexpressversion des legendären born in
the USA und es beginnt mit den Worten
Ukraine und Krämer Belarus und Moldova
das ist mein Land aber im Gegensatz zum
Bruce Springsteen Song der ein Protest
Lied ist ist dieser ein
ultra-nationalistischer propagandaerguss
mit anderen Worten in der russischen
nationalistischen Vorstellung ist die
Krim ein fester Teil des russischen
Imperiums einen ganz besonderer fast
schon heiliger Ort mit einem eigenen
besonderen und klar abgegrenzten Status
ja und das Problem ist dass sie
zumindest in diesem letzten Punkt
durchaus recht haben die Halbinsel
Krämer hat ihre eigene Geschichte die
sich von der der übrigen Ukraine
deutlich unterscheidet und unter
geopolitischen Gesichtspunkten ist sie
ein echter Joker eine wertvolle
Trumpfkarte für den der sie in seiner
Hand hält man könnte sagen das Putin
2014 wirklich den Jackpot geknackt hat
es war nämlich das einzige Gebiet wir
sind alexion er ohne jede Rücksicht
durchgezogen hat ich meine als die
Russen 2014 in die Ukraine eintragen
haben sie in Don was erstmal nicht
annektiert zumindest nicht offiziell die
Krim betrachtet der Krempel jedoch als
ebenso russisch wie Sankt Petersburg
selbst das meine Lieben Zuschauer ist
also die Lage KF will die Grenze zurück
moskau ist bereit alles zu tun um dich
zu verhindern und der besten ist dich
unendlich darüber ob er in diesem Fall
Partei ergreifen sollen wie ihr am Ende
verstehen werdet handelt es sich bei der
Creme um einen absoluten Schlüsselfaktor
nicht nur für die aktuelle Geostrategie
sondern auch historisch und vor allem
für die Zukunft sowohl der Ukraine als
auch Russlands und was vielleicht viele
überraschen mag die Krim ist auch eine
der wichtigsten Schlüssel für die
strategische Sicherheit Europas sowohl
in politischer als auch militärischer
als auch wirtschaftlicher Hinsicht ohne
eine nachhaltige Lösung der krimfrage
wird es kaum dauerhaften Frieden und
Stabilität auf dem Kontinent geben
können ja die Krim betrifft wirklich uns
alle viel mehr als wir denken um die
volle Bedeutung dieser Halbinsel zu
verstehen müssen wir uns jedoch
detailliert mit ihrer Geschichte
auseinandersetzen aber keine Angst dabei
wird es keine Sekunde langweilig denn
diese hat es wirklich in sich im Laufe
dieses Videos werdet ihr eine Menge
interessanter Fakten erfahren die euch
keine Ruhe mehr lassen werden und weil
es sich um ein so wichtiges und
tiefgreifendes Thema handelt das oft
leider nur stiefmütterlich behandelt
wird kommt das heutige Video wieder als
Zweiteiler im heutigen ersten Teil
werden wir die historischen Grundlagen
aufarbeiten wobei wir auch auf sehr
viele grausame Details stoßen werden die
für ein vollständiges
Geschichtsverständnis aber leider
unerlässlich sind ja es gibt kaum eine
Region mit einer spannenden daran aber
auch blutigerin Geschichte im nächsten
Teil schauen wir uns dann an wie es
heute um sie steht und wie ihre Zukunft
aussieht also warum ist die Creme für
Russland so wichtig wie könnte die
Ukraine sich zurückerhalten und
schließlich welches Szenarien können wir
erwarten in diesen zwei Teiler werden
wir all diese und noch viele weitere
Fragen rund um die Krempe Antworten und
zwar gleich nach der kurzen Botschaft
unseres tollen Sponsors denn schließlich
hat er das heutige Video mit seinem
Beitrag erst möglich gemacht als
aufmerksame Politik Zuschauer habt ihr
vielleicht schon bemerkt dass ich in den
letzten Monaten etwas abgenommen habe
vielleicht sieht man es mir sogar an
aber viel wichtiger ist dass ich mich
jetzt einfach viel fitter fühle und das
auch noch dauerhaft im vergangenen Jahr
war meine Arbeitsbelastung aufgrund des
Krieges enorm angewachsen und ich hatte
Schwierigkeiten den Stress auf gesunde
Weise zu kompensieren die Folge
Bewegungsmangel schlechte Ernährung und
österreichischen ich musste etwas
unternehmen als erstes habe ich meine
Morgenroutine umgestellt vor dem
proteinreichen und Zucker hat man
Frühstück kommt jetzt immer eine Runde
Krafttraining um das Muskelwachstum an
zu reden davor muss jedoch erste
Energiestoffwechsel in Schwung gebracht
werden und hierbei unterstützen mich
folgen Bestandteile meiner
allmorgendlichen Portion HG one Kupfer
Biotin Pantothensäure Diamin und die
Vitamine B2 B12 und C das ist übrigens
nicht einfach so daher gesagt sondern
der evidenzbasierte Tatsache klar ist
diese Routine ersetzt keine ausgewogene
Ernährung aber sie hilft mir dabei viel
gesünder und unbelasteter in den Tag zu
starten ich fühle mich gesättigt aber es
gibt nicht mehr dieses typische low nach
dem Frühstück wenn man Insulinspiegel
bleibt schön konstant das Ergebnis kann
sich wahrlich sehen lassen innerhalb von
fünf Monaten bin ich von 104 auf 93 Kilo
runter aber was wichtiger ist ich bin
nicht nur sechs Kilo Körperfett los
geworden an ihrer Stelle sind auch noch
gut zwei Kilogramm Muskelmasse getreten
natürlich ist LGO nicht nur für meinen
individuellen Anwendungsbereich geeignet
sondern bietet noch viele weitere
gesundheitliche Vorteile über die ihr
mehr erfahren könnt wenn ihr auf den
Link in der Beschreibung klickt dort
erfahrt ihr auch weitere Details darüber
welche Inhaltsstoffe genau welchen
Nutzen bringen und wie sie optimal
aufeinander abgestimmt sind um Synergie
Effekte und eine hohe Bio Verfügbarkeit
zu erzielen fakt ist HG One ist tot
freundlich und die 75 wertvollen
Mikronährstoffe werden aus echten
natürlichen veganen Nahrungsmitteln wie
Erbsen oder Soja gewonnen ohne
künstliche Zusatzstoffe außerdem
schmeckt es auch noch gut mir zumindest
ich empfehle euch auf jeden Fall mal
eine Ernährungsberatung zu machen um
festzustellen was ihr braucht um euch
besser zu fühlen und gesünder zu legen
mir persönlich hilft die oben genannte
Kombination mit LG one am besten
schreibt mir doch in die Kommentare wie
eure Morgenroutine aussieht und wenn sie
nicht zu ideal ist wie ihr sie auf
Vordermann bringen möchtet passen dazu
bietet LG1 unsere Community sogar eine
besonderes Angebot wenn du auf den Link
in der Videobeschreibung klickst
erhältst du bei Abschluss eines
monatlichen Abos einen kostenlosen
Jahresvorrat an Vitamin D3 und K5 und 5
praktische lG und travel Packs für
unterwegs gratis neue Kunden erhalten
außerdem das ageon Welcome Kit inklusive
schicke Aufbewahrungsdose und einen
praktischen Shaker zum Monats Packung
dazu das ganze ist ein Abo ohne
laufzeitbindung du kannst es jederzeit
nach Belieben anpassen pausieren oder
kündigen also worauf wartest du noch
probiert doch einfach mal ganz
unverbindlich aus und unterstütze auch
deine Ernährung auf einfache und gesunde
Weise übrigens dies ist unser erstes
Video in das wir Beiträge unserer
discord Community eingearbeitet haben
falls Ihr unseren neuen discord Server
zum Diskutieren und mitmachen noch nicht
kennt den Link findet ihr unten in der
Videobeschreibung auf ihn könnt ihr uns
zum Beispiel helfen die Qualität unserer
Videos durch aktive Mitarbeit zu
verbessern ebenfalls in der
Videobeschreibung findet ihr natürlich
wie immer auch eine Spenden Link für den
Fall dass ihr unsere Arbeit freiwillig
auch finanziell unterstützen möchtet wir
sind euch für jede Hilfe dankbar mit Day
und helft euch noch mehr und noch
bessere Videos zu liefern so und nun
lasst uns schnell in die Geschichte der
Krim abtauchenden genau dort finden wir
die ersten Antworten auf unsere
brennenden Fragen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
inzwischen dürftet ihr wahrscheinlich
alle die Karte der Creme im Kopf haben
doch der Teufel steckt im Detail bevor
wir uns also mit der Geschichte dieser
Region beschäftigen wollen wir uns auf
Ihre Geographie konzentrieren
die halbinselcreme wird von 2,4
Millionen Menschen bewohnt die
wichtigste Stadt ist sebasto Poll mit
547.000 Einwohner dort befindet sich
heute das Hauptquartier der russischen
Schwarzmeerflotte wer diese Enklave
kontrolliert beherrscht damit auch das
gesamte Asowsche Meer und das gesamte
nördliche Schwarze Meer tatsächlich
hatte die Ukraine bis 2014/12
funktionsfähige Häfen an ihre Küste für
Russland ist die Creme lebenswichtig um
einen Zugang zum Schwarzen Meer und zum
Mittelmeer zu haben sie ist eine der
wenigen warmwasserhäfen des Landes
darüber hinaus gibt es in den
Hoheitsgewässern des Landes nachgewiesen
Erdgasvorkommen zum einen dies gibts
Kaffee dem Osten der Halbinsel auf der
anderen Seite die ihm also schon mehr in
diesem Fall wäre es sogar relativ
einfach das Erdgas zu fördern da das
also schon mehr das flachste Meer der
Welt ist es ist nicht tiefer als 15
Meter
das wichtigste an der Creme ist jedoch
dass sie aufgrund ihrer geografischen
Lage perfekt geschützt ist sie auf dem
Seeweg einzunehmen ist für die Ukraine
ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit denkt daran
dass Russland hier seine gesamte
Schwarzmeerflotte stationiert hat um die
Ukraine kaum noch über nennenswerte
Seestreitkräfte verfügt daher werdet ihr
wahrscheinlich sagen okay dann sollen
sie die Creme eben auf dem Landweg
einnehmen tja nicht so schnell ich habe
euch ja bereits gesagt dass der Teufel
im Detail steckt auf den ersten Blick
sieht die Krim wie eine gewöhnliche
Halbinsel aus aber wenn wir uns einem
ganz bestimmten Detail nähern mich der
Landenge selbst die die Krim mit der
Ukraine verbindet finden wir genau jenen
sprichwörtlichen Teufel
[Musik]
wie ihr sehen könnt ist dieses ganze
Gebiet mit sehen und Sumpfgebieten
überzogen eigentlich gibt es nur drei
Punkte die die Halbinsel mit der Ukraine
verbinden das was sie hier sieht ist die
Landenge von pericord die zwischen 5 und
7 km breit ist Russland hat sie bereits
mit endlosen Schützengräben und anderen
Verteidigungsanlagen befestigt auf der
anderen Seite liegt die Halbinsel schon
Haare durch die eine von sehen umgebene
Straße führt auch dies ist ein sehr
leicht zu schützen dazugang schließlich
haben wir noch die arabert Nährung ein
schmaler 112 km langer Sandstreifen den
die Hosen ebenfalls leicht blockieren
können
mit anderen Worten eine Invasion der
Creme auf dem Landweg scheint fast
unmöglich gut aber was wenn es doch
irgendwie ginge ich meine in diesen
Krieg scheint ja alles möglich zu sein
dennoch eine Invasion der Creme wäre
eine ebenso ehrgeizige militärische
Operation wie die Landung der Alliierten
in der Normandie okay aber nachdem wie
die geographischen Gegebenheiten
überflogen haben kommt wir nun zur
Geschichte denn glaub mir es gibt
verdammt viele Details ohne deren
Kenntnis niemand begreifen kann wieso
die Krim ein absoluter schlüsselort ist
aufgepasst
die Insel der Invasionen
wie wir gesehen haben ist die Creme
verdammt schwer einzunehmen im Laufe der
Geschichte gab es jedoch unzählige
Imperien die genau das immer wieder
versucht haben die Halbinsel ist ein Ort
von enormer geopolitischer Bedeutung und
es handelt sich nicht um einen Zufall
dass die Konferenz von die Altar die für
viele den Beginn des Kalten Krieges
markierte wo stattfand genau Alter und
das ist eine Stadt die hier auf der
Creme liegt zwischen 1238 und 1449
gehörte die Halbinsel zum Mongolen Reich
danach war sie zwischen 1448 und 1783
ein dem Osmanischen Reich unterstelltes
Granat das erklärt warum einen Teil der
historischen Krim Bevölkerung die
sogenannten Tagen darstellen bei denen
es sich um Moslems handelt im Jahr 1783
schließlich nutze das russische Zaren
Reich die Schwäche der Osmanen um in
dieses Gebiet einzumarschieren und ja in
diesem Fall betraten sie die Halbinsel
Creme auf dem Landweg tatsächlich
versuchten es die Russen über mehrere
Jahre hinweg während drei verschiedene
Feldzüge und ist deswegen gelungen sie
zu erobern ja aber nicht ohne einen
hohen Preis zu zahlen dieser war es den
Zaren aber wert das Gebiet einzunehmen
und zu einem Teil des sogenannten
novorosia oder auch neue Russland zu
machen zudem auch andere Regionen wie
Odessa in der heutigen Ukraine gehörten
doch so sehr Ihnen der Besitz des
Territoriums am Herzen lag so sehr
hatten die russischen Zaren von Anfang
an ein Problem mit der lokalen
Bevölkerung die Tataren waren Muslime
und sie akzeptierten nicht die Autorität
der orthodoxen Christen daher wählten
die neuen Besatzer ihre typische
Strategie die rostifizierung der Krim
durch unvollkommen das heißt die
Deportation und Ermordung der lokalen
Bevölkerung und die Ansiedlung von
Russen fakt ist während bis in die
zweite Hälfte des 19 Jahrhunderts kaum
Russen auf der Krim lebten stieg ihre
Zahl anschließend rapide während von den
über 400.000 Kindertagen 300.000 von den
Zaren vertrieben wurden und ihre Zahl
bis 1944 auf Null sein dazu jedoch
später mehr aber wartet ein Moment in
die Geschichte ist hier noch lange nicht
zu Ende
[Musik]
wie ich schon sagte ist die Krim viel zu
interessant damit sie nicht nach kurzer
Zeit wieder zum Zankapfel wird und so
kam es 1853 zum sogenannten cremekrieg
in diesem Fall stand Russland den
Truppen der Osmanen der Briten und der
Franzosen gegenüber und welche Rolle
spielten Frankreich und das Vereinigte
Königreich in dieser Geschichte nun ganz
einfach sie wollten das Osmanische Reich
die heutige Türkei unterstützen um den
russischen nationalistischen
Expansionismus aufzuhalten wie ihr seht
ist dieser also wahrlich nichts Neues
allerdings so simpel ist das alles dann
doch wieder nicht schließlich hielt das
Osmanische Reich damals auch noch
bedeutende Teile Europas darunter zum
Beispiel Bulgarien besetzt eigentlich
wird die Bezeichnung Krieg der
tatsächlichen geopolitischen und
weltgeschichtlichen Bedeutung dieses
Konflikts nicht gerecht noch nicht mal
Orient Kriege oder türkische russische
Kriege wäre ob der massiven
Verstrickungen westlicher wie östlicher
Mächte angemessen schließlich fanden
Schlachten auch im Kaukasus auf dem
Balkan an der türkischen und Küste im
weißen und im Nordpazifik statt in der
öffentlichen Wahrnehmung und Erinnerung
meist Strich unterrepräsentiert kann der
Krimkrieg als Vorform des Ersten
Weltkriegs angesehen werden denn leicht
hätte er in einen Flächenbrand
Miteinbeziehung der mitteleuropäischen
Mächte posten und Österreich Ungarn
ausarten können der Krieg Krieg
markierte auch den ersten großen
industriellen und modernen Krieg in dem
Maschinen industriekapazitäten und
Logistik wichtiger waren als
herkömmliche militärische Strategien
während der Belagerung fand der erste
Stellungskrieg und Grabenkrieg der
Geschichte statt sowie auch die erste
richtige Materialschlacht diese neue Art
der Kriegsführung unterstützt durch
moderne Technologien und Waffensysteme
führte zu hohen Verlusten an
Menschenleben insgesamt verloren in
diesen zweieinhalbjährigen Konflikt über
600.000 Soldaten ihr Leben die meisten
Opfer fielen jedoch nicht durch direkte
Kämpfe sondern sterben an Hunger du hast
Krankheiten Seuchen oder aufgrund
unserer Behandlung ja zunächst wirkte
die Creme auch damals wie eine
uneinnehmbare Festung doch was glaubt
ihr schließlich passiert ist nun sie
fiel trotzdem in die Hände der Engländer
und Franzosen es gelang ihnen nämlich
sebastor Paul auf dem Seeweg einzunehmen
und mit dem Fall dieser Festung war das
Schicksal des restlichen Territoriums
und der dort befindlichen russischen
Truppen eigentlich besiegelt tja
eigentlich es stellte sich nämlich
heraus dass 10.000er siegreichen in
Silverstone stationierten Soldaten durch
Cholera und Ruhe dahin gerafft werden
sollten kein Wunder die riesigen
französischen Truppenlager bestanden nur
aus kalten feuchten Erdlöchern dann
jedoch kam schon wieder der nächste
Block ist die Besetzung der Restcreme
war sowieso nicht mehr notwendig die
Briten und Franzosen hatten fast alle
wichtigen Städte und heben erobert
darunter baller klar war kam ich und
catch russland hatte seine gesamte
schwarz mehr Flotte verloren und war
vollkommen isoliert in mittlerweile
waren auch Preußen und Schweden Norwegen
bereit der Anti russischen Koalition
beizutreten und so kam es zum
Friedensvertrag von Paris in dem
Russland zahlreiche Ländereien abtreten
musste die Städte der Grimm jedoch unter
der Auflage der Digitalisierung und
Demilitarisierung seiner
Schwarzmeerküste zurückerhielt auf diese
Weise wurde die Krim wieder russisch
zumindest administrativ und bis 1917 und
was war 1917 schon wieder los na der
russische Bürgerkrieg natürlich in
diesem Fall nutzten die grintertaren die
Instabilität in Folge des Verfalls des
Zarenreiches um die Volksrepublik im
auszurufen doch diese neue Republik
hatte nur eine kurze Lebensdauer sie
wurde bald von den Bolschewiki
zerschlagen in den folgenden Jahrzehnten
war die Krim eine Republik innerhalb der
Russischen Föderation die ihrerseits
Teil der Sowjetunion war bis zum Jahr
1951 und was geschah 1941 nun die
Operation Barbarossa der Überfall
Hitlers auf die Sowjetunion diesmal
waren es also die Deutschen mit ihren
Verbündeten den Rumänen die auf die Krim
einmarschierten ihr Feldzug sollte ein
Fegefeuer entfesseln wie ist die
geschundene Halbinsel noch nicht erlebt
hatte und das soll schon was heißen bei
ihrer wechselvoll und brutalen
Geschichte die Grausamkeiten sollten
dabei schon losgehen bevor sich auch nur
ein wehrmachtsoldat der kriminieren
konnte stalin ließ nämlich schon im
Vorfeld quasi vorsorglich die 53.000
creme-deutschen kurzerhand auf ewige
Zeiten deportieren um eine mögliche
Kollaboration mit den anrückenden
achsentruppen zu vermeiden und den
fiebergungsgefährt starben viele von
ihnen bereits auf der langen Fahrt in
die Vertreibung nach Kasachstan und
Sibirien dabei sah Berlin die Krim im
Rahmen der Operation war Barbarossa
zunächst eigentlich gar nicht als
besonders wichtiges Ziel an die
deutschen Militärplaner ging davon aus
dass sie quasi nebenbei eingenommen
werden könnte sobald der Großteil der
Roten Armee westlich des Erdball
vernichtet worden war dies sollte sich
jedoch als teurer Trugschluss erweisen
im Juni 1942 zerstörten sowjetische
Bomber von der Krim aus 12000 Tonnen Öl
in den Kriegs wichtigen rumänischen
ölraffin und plötzlich hatte die Creme
sogar die Aufmerksamkeit Hitlers
gewonnen er bezeichnete sie gar als
unsinkbaren Flugzeugträger und befahl
die erober der Ukraine und der Creme als
wichtige Ziele doch als die Truppen der
Achsenmächte vornehmlich aus deutschen
und Rumänen bestehend an der vorhin
erwähnten Landenge von perekopp ankamen
stießen sie auf erbitterten Widerstand
der Sowjetarmee ihre Verluste waren hoch
doch sie schafften schließlich den
Durchbruch dabei zeigte sich wie
verhasst die Russen bei Teilen der
lokalen Bevölkerung wirklich waren
20.000 rentataren meldeten sich prompt
und freiwillig zum Dienst in der
Wehrmacht doppelt so viele wie zur Roten
Armee eingezogen worden waren die
deutschen Truppen wurden als Befreier
von moskovita Joch gefeiert mit Hilfe
dieser Unterstützung schaffte es die
Nazi Armee die Creme rechts zügig bis
zum Herbst 1941 zu besetzen bis naja bis
auf die schwer befestigte Hauptstadt
Sebastian Paul mit ihrem Marine
Stützpunkt und diese Schlacht sollte
sage und schreibe 250 Tage dauern und so
eine der brutalsten des Krieges Austen
im Oktober und November 41 unternahmen
die Wehrmacht mehrere Versuche in die
Stadt vorzudringen einen großen Angriff
war für Ende November geplant wurde aber
wegen oder Regenfälle auf Dezember
verschoben doch auch dann gelang es den
Achsenmächten unter dem Kommando von
Erich von mahnstein nicht was dort Paul
während dieser ersten Operation
einzunehmen
[Musik]
die Rote Armee startet im Dezember 41
sogar eine Art biblische
Landungsoperation bei catch um die
Belagerung zu lösen und die Achsenmächte
zu zwingen ihre Kräfte zur Verteidigung
abzuziehen diese gegen Offensive sollte
Wasserfall vorerst für einige Zeit
entlasten und tatsächlich gelang es den
Nazis erst ein halbes Jahr später ins
sowjetischen Brücken im Osten Weg Grimm
zu zerstören und nach dem Scheitern
ihres ersten Angriff außer Paul
entschieden sich die Axt möchte den
Belagerungskrieg bis Mitte 42
vorzusetzen sie dürfen dabei die
eingekesselten sowjetischen Streitkräfte
im Rahmen der Operation Stör fangen zu
Lande zu Wasser und aus der Luft an aber
selbst dieser massiven kombinierten
Einkesselung und dem intensiven
Bombardement hielten die rotaristen und
die Schwarzmeerflotte Wochen lang stand
die Intensität der deutschen
Luftangriffe übertraf dabei bei weitem
frühere deutsche bombos auf Städte die
Warschau oder Rotterdam am Ende der
Belagerung standen in ganzer Wasser
Pollen nur noch 11 Gebäude die
sowjetischen Verluste betrogen über
200.000 Mann die der Achsenmächte knapp
36 dieses krasse Missverhältnis war auch
darauf zurückzuführen dass die
nazi-truppen selbst 10.000 flüchtende
rutarmesten gnadenlos bombardierten und
brutale liquidierten und nach der
kompletten Einnahme der Creme
entfalteten die neuen Besatzer denn auch
ein weiteres Terrorregime ebenfalls mit
den Ziel der unvollkommen als erstes
wurde die gesamte jüdische Bevölkerung
ermordet hitler wollte die Halbinsel mit
Bezug auf die germanischen grimm-goten
in guten Gau umbenennen und mit
deutschsprachigen Südtirolern besiedeln
um den Anliegen der Verbündeten Italo
Faschisten zu entsprechen diese wiederum
aus ihrer Heimat zu deportieren aber
dazu sollte es nicht mehr kommen denn
eines war klar Ruhe sollte auf der Krim
nicht so schnell wieder einkehren
tausende sowjetisches Soldaten und
Zivilisten leisteten noch bis in den
später 42 in den Katakomben bei Cash er
bitteten Widerstand gegen die Deutschen
und bereits gegen Ende 43 unternahmen
die Rote Armee ebenfalls bei catch eine
weitere antibiotische Landungsoperation
um die Rückeroberung der Creme
vorzubereiten zwar gelang es den
Achsenmächten in schweren Kämpfen ein
weiteres Vordringen der Sowjets zu
verhindern dennoch schuf die Landung
eine günstige Ausgangsposition für die
kommende Schlacht um die Krim denn
früher hat 1944 hatte sich das Blatt an
der Ostfront schließlich bereits lange
gewendet die Sowjets standen wieder vor
den Toren der Krim mit einer knappen
halben Millionen rotaristen während die
Wehrmacht die Halbinsel zu einer wie sie
glaubte uneinnehmbaren Festung ausgebaut
hatte auf der 250.000 Mann dem roten
Sturm trotzdem würden und wieder mal
lautete die Frage würde den Song jetzt
nur die doppelte Truppenzahl ausreichen
um die Deutschen wieder zu vertreiben
wir alle wissen ja mittlerweile dass der
Angreifer zahlenmäßig wesentlich
überlegen sein muss um bei einer so
gewaltigen offensive Operationen derart
unwegsamem Gelände Erfolg zu haben
tatsächlich war das Oberkommando des
Heeres doch einen Tag vor dem Beginn der
Schlacht um die Grenze schwer davon
überzeugt dass die Verteidigung der Krim
doch auf längere Sicht gewährleistet ist
und wenn man die nackten taktischen und
logistischen Gegebenheiten so wie die
ressourcenverhältnisse auf beiden Seiten
betrachtete war diese Einschätzung gar
nicht mal so ab sie ähnelt in
papierender Form der Denkweise nach der
auch noch heutige deutsche und
österreichische Militär ist ob im oder
außerdienst die Lage in der Ukraine
beurteilen im November da 43 war die
Wehrmacht nämlich auf ihrer gesamten
Frontlinie östlich der Grimm
zurückgedrängt worden und hatte sich von
dort über die Meerenge von catch auf die
Krems zurückgezogen das gleiche spielte
sich auch in der süd-ukraine ab so dass
die Rote Armee an der vorhin erwähnten
von perekopf zum Stehen kam die
Wehrmacht hatte ihre Kräfte also auf der
massiert und konnte sie auch dann noch
erfolgreich halten nachdem sie auf dem
Landweg abgeschnitten worden war weil
sie ihre Truppen über das Schwarze Meer
versorgen konnte Hitler hier ist nämlich
für kriegswichtig die Krim um jeden
Preis zu halten da ihr Verlust die
Haltung der Türkei negativ beeinflussen
würde und auch die rumänischen Ölfelder
wieder durch sowjetische Luftangriffe
gefährdet worden werden und während er
zum Beispiel die Evakuierung Gottes
ausgemiste schickte er weitere
Verstärkungen auf die Krim der Punkt ist
trotz ihrer strategischen Bedeutung
warte es ist daher während der nächsten
fünf Monate nicht mehr eine voll un
Gespräche Invasion der Grenze starten
abgesehen von den landungsoperationen an
der Straße von Kersch und bei perekopf
um die feindlichen
Verteidigungsstellungen zu sondieren und
zumindest Brückenköpfe aufzubauen erst
am 8 April 1944 startete die Rote Armee
ihre Sturm über perikord im Norden drei
Tage darauf auch von Osten her über den
Brückenkopf bei Kersch ihr Vorstoß wurde
dabei wiederum tatkräftig durch
Partisanen unterstützt ähnlich wie die
Tataren nämlich den deutschen geholfen
hatten fühlten sich nun viele
ukrainische und russische Bewohner der
Krim den rotaristen verbunden sie
kundschafteten die Stellungen der Achse
ausführten im Rücken des Gegners
erfolgreiches Sabotageaktion durch
zerstörten Verbindungslinien und
Eisenbahn legten Hinterhalte an und
verhinderten umgekehrt dass die Nazis
Städte Industrieanlagen und
Infrastruktur auf ihrem Rückzug
zerstören konnten die Deutschen und
Rumänen mussten den auch Richtung
servustopol zurückweichen und planten
die Stadt genauso als Festung zu halten
wie es die Russen drei Jahre zuvor getan
hatten ja Hitler höchstpersönlich Befall
die
festungsbedingt zu halten die
Befestigung der Stadt waren jedoch nie
wieder hergestellt worden und Sebastopol
war nicht mehr jene starke
Verteidigungsposition die es 1941
gewesen war bereits Ende April Dranges
vorwärts in die Außenbezirke vor Ort
eroberten die Stadt nach weniger als
einem Monat Kampf dabei übten sie
unerbittlich Rache für die blutige Jagd
der Nazis auf ihre fliegenden Kameraden
zwei Jahre zuvor voll beladene
Truppentransporter mit denen die
abrückenden Besatzer nach Rumänien
evakuiert werden sollten wurden
gnadenlos versenkt 60 Schiffe gingen
verloren wie viele Soldaten der Achse
dabei ertranken oder anderweitig ins
Leben kam ist gar nicht so exakt bekannt
die Zahlen schwanken zwischen 60.000 und
100000 die Verluste der Roten Armee
beliefen sich dabei offiziell auf 85
000 Soldaten und wieder fällt auf die
Verluste der Angreifer waren geringer
als die der Verteidiger ist der Mythos
der Grimm als unannehbarer Festung oder
zumindest schwer einnehmbare Festung
also nichts als das ein Mythos nun wir
werden sehen auf jeden Fall sollte auch
diese Befreiung für viele krimbewohner
zum Albtraum werden denn stalin wollte
sich zunächst an den Kollaborateuren
rechnen und zwar ganz so wie es sein
Stil war Kollektiv und unbarmherzig er
nutzte die Gelegenheit um die Creme
weiter zu russifizieren indem er die
200.000 verbliebenen Tataren auch noch
deportieren ließ und durch ethnische
Russen aus anderen Landesteilen ersetzte
am Ende seiner Terrorherrschaft lebte so
gut wie kein Kind hat Haare mehr auf der
Halbinsel dafür war die Zahl der
ethnischen Russen dort auf fast eine
Million gestiegen die der Ukraine auf
200.000 ja wenn es einen Ort gibt an dem
sich ethnisch motivierte
massenverfolgung Unterdrückung
Vertreibung Auslöschung und Substitution
auf unzählige Weise wie in einem
Brennglas konzentrieren und immer wieder
wiederholen dann ist es die Creme die
könnte Tagen sind das bekannteste
Beispiel aber bei Leibe nicht das
einzige sie sind ein totsprachiges
muslimisches Volk das sich lange vor den
Russen zwischen dem 10 und 13
jahrhundert auf der Grimm ansiedelte wie
wir im zweiten Teil dieses Videos sehen
werden ihre Verfolgung leider bis heute
nicht aufgehört allerdings könnten sie
auch jetzt bei der Rückeroberung der
Krim eine wichtige Rolle spielen zu den
billiger bekannten Opfern der Russen auf
der Krems zählen die Armenier diese
lebten dort ebenfalls seit den
Mittelalter und waren nach der
russischen Annexion im Laufe der Zeit
mehrfach Vertreibungen ausgesetzt ein
ähnliches Schicksal traf auch die
griechischen Gemeinschaften auf der
Krimi ebenfalls im 18 und 19 Jahrhundert
von der russischen Herrschaft betroffen
waren und das obwohl das orthodoxe
Griechenland während des Kriegs mit dem
zahnreich gegen die Osmanen verbündet
war dann wären dann natürlich die schon
erwähnten in deutschen die von Katharina
der Großen im 18 Jahrhundert als Sieger
angelockt worden um die Wirtschaft der
Creme auf Vordermann zu bringen sie
etablierten dort erfolgreiche
landwirtschaftliche Gemeinden und
liebten über ein Jahrhundert auf der
Krimis Stalin den ganzen den Chaos
ausmachte und last but not least die
Juden die sich sogar in drei
unterschiedliche Gruppen aufhalten aus
Mittel und Osteuropa stammende Arsch
Gymnasien die jede Sprachen die Krim
Schatten die bereits im Mittelalter aus
der Türkei auf die Krim gekommen waren
und eine Turksprache mit hebräischen
Einflüssen Sprachen und ebenfalls
zurücksprachigen Carrera die
ausmesopotamien stammen und deren
Geschichte auf der Krim bis ins achte
Jahrhundert reichte all diese jüdischen
Gemeinschaften auf der Krim wurden
während des Zweiten Weltkriegs durch die
Nazis vor allem von ss-einsatzgruppen
fast vollständig vernichtet ja die Krim
ist ein Ort der Völkermord Vertreibung
und unmenschliche unvollkommen immer
wieder erlebt hat und leider bis heute
erlebt aber vielleicht fragen sich an
dieser Stelle manche Wand die Fremden
eigentlich Teil der Ukraine wurde nun
dazu müssen wir wissen 1954 warten in
jedem Jahr beschloss der damalige
sowjetische Staatschef Nikita Großstadt
dass die Halbinsel Krämpfe von der
russischen sozialistischen sowjetischen
Republik an die ukrainische
sozialistisches sowie Republik übergehen
sollte aber warum eigentlich nun er tat
dies aus einem rein pragmatischen Grund
der einfachste Weg um diese Halbinsel zu
versorgen führt nun mal über die Ukraine
es ist also nur logisch dass diese
Region auch von Archiv aus verwaltet
wird ich meine es gab damals keine
Grenzen zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine für den Alltag der Sowjetbürger
spielte es also keinerlei Rolle ob Sie
zu Russland oder zur Ukraine gehörte
solange sie immer noch Teil der
Sowjetunion war administrativ und
wirtschaftlich war es jedoch für alle
von Vorteil wenn Sie eine Einheit mit
der Ukraine bilden würde natürlich
dachte damals noch niemand im Traum
daran dass die UdSSR eines Tages
zerfallen und sich auflösen könnte einen
durchaus realer Traum vieler sowie
Bürger war jedoch die Krim selbst die
für viele Sowjet Eliten zum beliebten
Urlaubsziel wurde viele hochrangige
kommunistische Parteifunktionäre
unterhielten hier eigene
Ferienresidenzen und verbrachten dort
gerne eine entspannte Zeit am Strand und
damit wären wir auch schon im Jahr 1991
dem Jahr in dem die Ukraine ohne
abhängig wurde
was seitdem geschehen ist werden wir uns
jedoch im zweiten Teil dieses Videos
ansehen dann werden wir die Fragen
klären sind die Menschen auf der Creme
wirklich glücklich darüber ein Teil
Russlands zu sein was ist eigentlich mit
den kindertaren passiert spielen sie
heute noch eine Rolle und wieso ist die
Krim eigentlich eine oberste Priorität
für Putin warum ist sie auch für die
Ukraine überlebenswichtig kann KFC
überhaupt zurückerobern und falls ja wie
könnte die Strategie dazu aussehen gibt
es vielleicht auch eine Alternative und
rationale Lösung falls euch die
Antworten auf diese Fragen interessieren
vergesst bitte nicht das Abo unbedingt
mit glücklichen um sie nicht zu
verpassen bis dahin könnt ihr aber schon
mal selbst ein paar Fragen diskutieren
welche Lehren können sowohl die Ukraine
als auch die Russen aus der Historie der
Grenzen was denkt ihr wieso die
Halbinsel der Art wichtig für beide
Länder ist werden Sie bereit sein so
viel für sie zu opfern wie die
historischen Belagerung und Verteidiger
wie blutig könnte eine Schlacht um die
Krämpfe werden und welche Strategie
würdet ihr wählen um sie zu erobern oder
zu verteidigen wie immer sind wir auf
eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat und vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja
gibt uns bitte ein Like also mit euren
Freunden und diskutiert es mit ihnen
natürlich freuen uns auch wie gesagt
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
dem Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]